The overall course is broken
into three mini courses.
>> The first one is
Manipulating Financial Data in Python.
>> In this first mini course, we show
you how to read historical financial
data into Python and manipulate it
using powerful statistical algorithms.
>> The second one is
Computational Investing.
>> In the second mini course,
we show you the algorithms, methods and
models used by hedge funds and
investment banks to manipulate and
work with financial data.
>> And the last one is
Learning Algorithms for Trading.
>> In this last mini course,
we pull everything together.
We take what you learned in the first
two mini courses, show you how to take
that data and use it with machine
learning algorithms like Q learning and
random forests to build
trading algorithms.
Now, our goal is that after you complete
this course you'll be equipped to
join a trading system development team.
Say a hedge fund or an investment bank.
But I want to emphasize that you
shouldn't immediately begin automatic
trading.
This course is just a starting point to
teach you some of the things that you
need to do that well.
But, again, it's just a starting point.